et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un ou deux mois quand tu étais au pays
de gêne à dire tu sais faut compter 3 le
progrès est bien le grand iata ne le
permettent pas voilà à quoi je passe ma
vie à balayer à lyon comme moi avec mon
physique sera plus une mode est à la
télévision c'est pas de chance je suis
balayeurs et les grandes dates à cocher
d'abyane roi lors il n'y a pas de son
bestiaire bien si on est trop mal quand
vous vous êtes vous là un
prestidigitateur c'est un beau métier
temps mais frey la coc mal ici logique
je ne suis pas apprécié à sa juste
valeur les mois dans the ballet là mais
d'autres aspirations tu et à toi tu as
dit aspirations le verbe aspire un
aspire aspirent aux aspirateurs anna
vous ne savez pas considéré après
aspirons
je dis bien aspirateur aspirateur qui
aspirent au plat et pourquoi maintenant
tout tout tout est encore tout aller
laisse tomber tombale un bon jeune abby
j'ai ce qu'il te font dans des trésors
par ici par ici à t'envoyer il doit être
dans ce coffre e adultes ont repêché
alors c'est dans celui ci peut
travailler trouvait d'impatience dans
l'état de pará tout est là n'ont rien de
ce père lorsqu'on et ordonne à 6 m
voici un morceau est un tuyau c'est un
petit cowboy
voici la suite est à faire dans la vie
voici un autre morceau tout elle là est
toute la has éprouvette d'une lunette
non pas du tout ça c'est le boss tu vois
alors tiens prends encore ce morceau est
un papillon
alors à présent il faut assembler tous
les morceaux claude ap le studio à se
trompent
l'entonnoir au bout du tuyau
quand vint mama le manche ici et tu lis
très fort
gravé par an
je vous promets qu'on obtiendra alors tu
placent les listes sur le dessus c'est
la force motrice d'un papillon mon jeune
ami c'est fini ton aspirateur est prêt à
possible est un aspirateur et akwaba
père ben en aspirateurs sert à aspirer
j'aspire tu aspires nous aspirons c'est
le programme que l'appui sur le bouton
et sa des bars
[Musique]
et arrêtez maman de ma part
l'aspirateur damman il la pousse bien
année égale quoi en tout cas pour cela
que tu voudras titus j'étais trou
vingtaine d'états musigny qui peut pas
dire le contraire du début je fais pas
du tout quand y'a qu'à zafir martyrs où
l'aspirant quoi où tu toi ton petit
menteur va s'était joué sérieux le web
les réunions de grandes vacances et un
aspirateur est le progrès quoi le
produit mais vous et bien le mets est
bien le problème moi je ne confisque
voilà le le progrès m'appartient 90
euros ce bonhomme et b le progrès est à
moi voilà et moi j'avais m'amuser c'est
pour ça que j'avais confisqué la petite
fille djezzy le plus beau et non mais
c'est une plume au repos c'est bien le
droit de m'amuser
netiq urieta faisait du bruit tout à
l'heure il doit y avoir eu secret d'un
ce progrès la wii n'a jamais vraiment
lâché dans la nature
la main mais je cours titus titus ils
ont aimé la poule honneur du métier et
l'aide au secours à nantes aurillac à
être ménages alors que tu apprécies tu
s'arrête le procureur en a on n'arrête
pas le progrès mais je te le dis tu sais
leur veto le pour moi et voilà
thaï prendrait tard et est intitulé je
te le rend ton progrès ça ne m'amuse pas
du tout c'est trop dangereux veulent
bien moi le progrès sa maman beaucoup
mais faut savoir s'en servir
et après après c'est une autre histoire
bah